[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hello welcome to Brewers choice class my
name is Rebecca I'm here in the st.
Louis chess club in my last day in this
Grandmaster Residence program yeah what
are we gonna do today well we're gonna
analyze the gains from the YouTube users
from the st. Louis chest left channel
yeah so I see there are already some
people there in the chat I can see
desert lightning Aditya Chandra Orlando
Luis Pedro laughs OH
so I will love you to participate during
the class and when we asking you a lot
of questions and please do you guys have
any comments or whatever just don't
hesitate to ask
so the first game that we analyzed is
from Nicholas or Nicholas it comes with
a message he saying well hey this is my
game of chess on real opus clothes
variation where I used the idea of
Marshall attack and let me see where I
was yeah but we have the knight in the
game I have sacrificed a pond to slow
White's development
I searched only chest data and there was
no equal game to this one please take a
look I got this idea from an analogy
that drum master Dennis Bors made on
this particular video thank a lot and
Greg Borg and the st. Louis chess club I
loved your videos so let's go ahead guys
so evil was played and E 5 was played by
Nicholas Knight seats Knight f3 knight
c6 Bishop b5 do you all guys know how
this is called right this is the Spanish
real Lopez variation one of the most
used lengths in chess in top tournaments
right here black has two main options so
the first move is a six then Knight f6
is also possible I guess you also know
how this is called it's called the
Berlin difference right
having it has been used many many times
the top tournaments
this game black chose to go a six
what can now decide to take on c6 text
change variation of the Spanish real
Lopez or Bishop a4 the mainline not f6
and short Castle just in case you guys
like tricky lines I recommend you to
check d4 here is the so called I think a
slow bacon attack so okay the main line
is short Castle here and then black
normally plays Bishop e7 also Knight
takes e4 is possible here in this
position and then after d4 b5 Bishop b3
D 5 D takes e5 which B is 6 this is one
of the most common lines in the Spanish
- but Bishop e7 it's really not form of
so don't think that you can win the
effect 1 because after takes takes
Knight e4 black and just simply take on
info back right and nothing happens for
black here so that's why in these
positions rook e1 is the main move also
d3 is really interesting and but rook e1
just protects the e4 pawn and now you
want to go like C 3 and d 4 and try to
install a beautiful Center with these
pawns right here black plays b5 Bishop
b3 and d6 and now blacks creating in a
position of threat any from the YouTube
channel you guys see what's Black's
threatening here in this position for
example if I play a tree here what will
you play if I play a tree
hello all right Kevin how are you doing
everything okay yeah you're staying for
the class
you're staying for the class er yeah
okay so we're checking a game from
Nicolas okay one of the users from the
YouTube channel and here black has just
played d6 okay what do you think black
wants to play in the next move for
example if I play H 3 H 8 3 so how can
you win the bishop pair here in this
position yeah from blacks point of view
the bishop pair so that means that you
get a bishop for a knight yeah so how
can you get the bishop from B 395
perfect that's why I'm here after d6
black's threatening to play Knight a5
and then get the bishop rare before it
was not possible because you play 95 the
pawn on e5 is hanging right so that's
why black plays d6 and now how do we
avoid that how do we stop 95 so we have
to make some room for our Bishop right
so what do you play this Bishop where
you mana move it to d5 no because Knight
takes d5 a tree that's an interesting
move
but in these positions black or white
wants to install a beautiful Center and
that's why white players play c3 here so
after 95 you got the c2 squared to
escape and then you want to put the
default point you see the idea that
makes sense right alright but instead in
this game black played short Castle it's
also a very common move here and blacks
idea is after d3 see 3 here you know the
marshal attack no ok there is a pawn
sacrifice really interesting for black
here in this position it's d5 sorry g5e
txt 590 xt5
and looks like white is winning upon
right so Knight takes e5 rook takes and
now you're attacking this knight black
place c6 and there's a lot of
compensation you want to go Bishop d6
Queen h4 and you see there are a lot of
pieces in the background here for the
white player right so you are clearly
living in development with the black
pieces and that's why black has a lot of
compensation in this position so yes
tell me
yeah you tell me yeah this wreck they do
mean this rook to e5 right but the thing
is you grab it you grab upon right so
that's the reason you move the rook
there to get upon for free it's not that
you want to move the rook to if I
because it's gonna gonna get easily
attacked but the thing is you're
grabbing upon that's why the rook is
only five but okay this is the marshal
attack but there are some anti marshals
here for white for example they move d3
or the move a for trying to open the a
file or I seen the game they move d4
here which is very interesting
now black plate it takes d4 I want to
ask you
sorry in the game black played d6 I want
to ask you what would you play it black
takes on d4 guys from the YouTube
channel as well
what's your name sorry Ethan Ethan and
Kevin are here with me and people from
the YouTube channels as well so Ethan
what would you play here or Kevin what
we play here with the white pieces
would you pawn to c3
that's a pawn sacrifice very interesting
my question is can you take the pawn on
d4 with the night yeah and then you take
that night with the Queen but that's
good enough it's not a sacrifice I mean
you are a pawn down now with white right
and then you should get the pawn back at
some point if five is very interesting
as hey their skills edita sahat are same
in the youtube channel the probable
Knight takes e4 is actually that you
lose the game Knight takes e4 Queen
takes d4 and how black white loses the
game what do you play with the black
piece is now come on come on Kevin
attack my pieces trap my bishop trap the
bishop trap it go free a five value sure
but then I can just play a three and
then the bishop is not trapped come on
drop it
you got five seconds in the clock see
five great see five the point is
whenever wherever the Queen goes you go
see four and the bishop is trapped right
so let's say queen d1 + c4 that's why
you can't really take on the four with
the white pieces but for example you
could play it sorry
d4 it takes it takes e4 you could play
e5 and the knight has to go back to e8
and now there are many moves for example
Bishop d5 but even 94 now it's possible
because there is square on d5 where do
you attack the rook you see right but in
this game nicholas played d6 very normal
game protecting the center right and at
this point the white player did move
that I really don't like it whenever I
want I have some space advantage like
here you see that my pawns are on the
4th rank black central pawn it's only 5
but the other one is from d6 you
normally want to keep the tension on the
center here white player to con 85
I would have preferred to play something
like c3 at this point just reinforcing
the center right sorry
yeah that makes sense right but then at
this point why - Connie 590 85 90 85 D
takes e5 and then at this point the
white player played Bishop d5 what do
you think about this move
yeah and then you take the bishop back
with the pawn and that's good for black
for black or white
yeah but the bishop pair is really
important so if you you don't have a
good reason you shouldn't give your
bishops okay the bishop air is something
really important in modern chess okay
and look at this Bishop on b3 is doing a
fantastic job in this diagonal right has
an open diagonal in it's putting
pressure in this important square f7
right so that's why Bishop d5 is
actually a bad move because after Knight
takes e5 it sexy five now black has the
bishop pair and it's much better but
okay the game continues it's not the end
of the wall of course yeah and yeah hey
there hey there set the great thing yeah
he said like the bishop pair is really
important so Bishop d7 was played
okay now you could play f6 to protect
this pawn on e5 he played Bishop d7 and
now white took only five looks like it's
a pawn up but as you can see we're in a
similar position to the one that just we
just saw before right we were talking
about the Marshall attack right where
black has sacrificed upon and it has a
lot of attacking in return right and at
this point after Bishop d6 Black has a
lot of compensation we have to say
what's not necessary to sacrifice the
pawn on e5 you could just play f6 and
then put the bishop on day six but still
black position is so nice that there is
a lot of compensation here
rook a1 and then what would you play
here with the black pieces we need five
looks impossible right
Queen h4 great attacking I really maybe
I just made it out sorry Kari so Queen
h4 now White has to protect the eggs to
pawn right so that's why you play g3
Queen h3 and now white played Queen f3
trying to go to g2 and to exchange some
pieces do you think you will have to
exchange pieces with the black pieces
now here or you should keep the Queen's
in the board
why because you see we are a pawn down
with black right so we don't want to
exchange material right we should keep
the Queen's in the board to attack our
opposite King okay so Bishop g4 was
played Queen g2 and now what do you play
here with black yeah so exactly perfect
Queen eight five perfect and now you are
threatening to bring this bishop to f3
and whites Queen has holy dis ugly
square here
why plate 92 and now once we have
developed all our pieces we bring the
rest of the heavy pieces to the action
how great this is what Nikolas did he
played a really good game
rukia now you see that white has a lot
of development problems because this we
should be still on c1 and now after the
trade of roofs
Ruki a true key you can see that you are
threatening to bring this route to the
background right and it's extremely hard
for y to stop right so in the game black
plague what sorry white played Knight e4
how do we finish the white player with
the black pieces imagine Magnus Carlsen
you know magnus carlsen no you know
Fabiano card wanna know you don't know
if a yellow card wanna Ethan are you
sure about that
Ireland so for yellow card 1 is the
number 2 of the wall and you know where
he lives here in st. Louis
didn't you know that okay so he was
fighting for the world title this year
against Magnus Carlsen Magnus Carlsen is
the best player in the world from Norway
okay so how do you finish your opponent
here
Kevin it's an easy move yeah some people
already in the YouTube channel they
found out that screw that's great Kevin
he's about three you attacked my queen
and then you attack my knight and then I
can just resign let's say queen of one
just rookie four right and this is how
Nicholas won his game really nice game
for Nicholas the key moment was this
Bishop d5 this is a really bad move you
never want to give up your bishop pair
and then this bishop was doing a
fantastic job on this Iona
so for example something like Queen e2
and then you want to develop with f3
Bishop e3 92 even a four um White's okay
alright let's check the second game from
today so gang from seer Maurer it comes
with a message to this game was played
in an inter college sports tournament
iron white with the name
relax monster playing for win this was
the final chess match between our
College ups I I am Sigma we want
congratulations so he said he was
driving the white pieces right yes so d4
Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight c3 Bishop before
you know how this is called
you remember so this is called the
dragon are you sure the Dutch the dragon
right now that's not a dragon that's
more like a lion but but now this is
called the nimzo-indian defense okay
it's it's very common among top players
- one of the most solid defenses to a
tree that's a very natural move so black
wants to just to normal moves yeah just
develop the minor piece is going for
sure castle and then you want to give
the bishop prep but you get something in
return for example what do you get in
return
now you take on c3 what's good for black
here after giving up Joe Bishop earth I
[Music]
mean what have you what have you
achieved with the black pieces you have
ruined white pawn structure right you
got double pawns here so that's why it's
alright to give the bishop in okay in
this game Queen c2 was played what's the
idea of Queen c2 just precisely to take
on c3 with the Queen and then your pawn
structure is not ruined
okay so sure castle was played 93 96 and
a3 was played here very natural move
I like Bishop d2 here or even Bishop g5
I played this with the white pieces in
tournaments and a tree now Bishop took
on c3 how would you take on c3 now with
the Queen right that was precisely the
idea and our friends here mouth he took
with a pawn I don't like this move I
think the whole point of playing Queen
c2 is just to take on c3 with a quick
right make sense
so B takes c3 and now plug play d6
in order to go for d5 and try to create
some corner play in in the center white
plate efore and if i was played here
okay
this position is really interesting for
example did you go d5 this night is
coming to a 5 and then there could be
some pressure in the future this c4
point for example b6 Bishop h6 right and
this point could suffer so h3 was played
and now it takes d4 see text e4 and what
do you play here with the black pieces
for lambda what do you play here
but we have to pay attention that tea
skin is in the center so there could be
some tactics yeah Ruki 8 or even more
straight 95 I'll just take that 94 very
good Ethan
the point is you can't take because
there is Ruki 8 right you see some
problems to rise when when you're keen
is in the center
okay so 94 was very interesting
still yeah Bishop d3 and then after
Knight f6 White has a lot of
compensation here you've got the bishop
pair which is extremely important Bishop
g5 or even Bishop e2 d5 and there's some
compensation here all right so let's go
back a little bit so in the game black
played d6 a very slow move that there's
no point of basics in this in this in
this position you should hurry up
because if what consolidates the
position let's say Bishop d3 and short
castle is much better because you've got
the bishop er you got the center what
else you want in life yeah what else
Kevin what do you want pizza do you like
pizza you like pineapple in pizza I
think that's a crime right pineapple in
pizza Italians pull kill us yeah so
black played b6 and this is a very slow
move so Bishop d3 was played by CM our
our friend and now Bishop a6 with the
port on C 3 with a double pawns here it
makes sense to develop this Bishop to a
6 because c4 is hard to protect but with
the Queen and d3 in sorry with the Queen
and c2 and the bishop on d3 is just
impossible to capture this pawn right
exactly and it's hard to to create
pressure on this c4 point so that's why
b6 and followed by addition a six not
very good right so sure Castle was
played nine a five he continues with
this plan and now there was a good move
for white here tactics again tactics if
I've Kevin you are doing extremely well
a5 so deflection do you kick this night
and then what happens what did nice when
did this night goes back to e8
what happens come on you take the pawn
with a check right Bishop takes 87 and
let's say for example Bishop f5 and then
you want to call queenie for or Bishop
g5 and then Queen 84 and Queen h7
checkmate very tough position for black
man instead similar played Bishop g5
which is a normal move but if I was
already winning and at this point black
played we are threatening if I right and
then win a piece so that's why black try
to amp in by playing eight six here and
now black sorry white again did I move
that I don't like what did we say about
the bishop pair we should we don't have
a good reason we shouldn't give our
bishops okay so white took an f6 and
then after Queen f6 black was already
fine here Bishop h4 was a better move
and for example what will you play here
after g5 now it takes very interesting
cabin now as you can see is almost
impossible for black to unpin there are
a lot of moves for example 'if I've also
f-4e five also Ruki one rookie three
route g3 looks like very dangerous for
black alright so at this point why took
an f6 I don't like that move Queen f6
are now II five he could
right if I before and he was winning
upon but now the point is on 86 and
there's no free material for us right
yeah he's got pressuring the Queen
that's right
but black is not gonna blended the Queen
right so Jen are gonna play here Ruby
eight right Ethan
so black took takes any five and now
rugby eight and now you see there's a
lot of pressure going on in white Center
but here why started to play a little
bit tricky he went for Bishop f5 what do
you think it's White's idea in this
position so for example if I take on d4
what do you think is doing with the
bishop on f5 okay so you mean like
you're expecting black to take on f5 but
okay that's not going to happen right
but you know this bishop is targeting
this d7 square so now 97 fork right now
you can't take because the bishop is
protecting this piece and now White's
gonna wait that win an exchange so
that's why here a rook takes d4 it's not
a very good move there was a very good
move for black here let's see you can
find it Orlando
taking this before I think just Knight
takes e4 you can take that's alright
yeah Queen takes Queen a5 Queen c7 no
it's about equalia
so g6 that's right Kevin g6 deflection
you're right
yeah because now if the bishop comes
back to d3 or e4 you can take the pawn
because there is no fork on this salmon
right and if the bishop goes to g4 we
can insist how do we insist
eight-five the point is I guess are not
so sure if black a white retreats the
bishop we take on d4 and if 97 what do
we play here with the black pieces
take one did this have a night
are you sure I want to take your queen
Ethan
be careful move the Queen for for
example g7 let's say night f8 and now
the best move is take the bishop on the
night is trap and then we get to pieces
for the work on black spider now you see
the idea but instead in this position
after Bishop f5 black played Queen d6
and then again the position is more or
less balanced rook F t1 and now I move
we shouldn't play was played in the game
f6 now there are a lot of holes here and
our friend punished pretty well how do
you punish black for doing this
you see something you see the screen
with about seven great teenage 896 King
eighty-seven take the rook there was an
even better move here in this position
defy see if I was incredibly good I'm
gonna try to show you Wow
why after night of fate King g8 night g6
black can take on c4 and this actually
will happen in the game and it's not so
clear right but see if I was brilliant
move here in this position because what
do you play B takes D takes and now
whatever you go with your queen there's
going to be Sun discovered check where
I'm trapping your queen right you go to
this seven not afraid you go to e6 not
afraid you got to c6 95 or 97 right and
you take everything on d1 and King g6
what do you play here with the white
pieces
Queen d3 are you sure you put bet I why
not the bishop can't be careful yeah
that's a possibility but nothing special
happens I just bring the King to f7 just
attack the unprotected pieces how do you
attack the unprotected pieces here come
on Kevin I believe in you Kevin come on
it's an easy move when a for right and
now you're gaining you winning a piece
and queen g4 queen g4 yeah king f7 and
queen a4 right both work exactly Pat
okay in the game he played night fa the
most natural move of course kingi 896
Bishop c4 and now nights for Wars play
what do you think about this move it's a
big mistake why No
No tactics again black wins material
black mom some wins material Orlando do
you see okay Bishop III right come on
that was an easy one Kevin Bishop III
was played queen g6 bishop take c1 rook
takes it one
okay Knight a5 intermediate move red
move now Queen d7 Luke take c1 sorry d1
and here
c5 was played a very bad move because
now what do you play nine eight six I
come here to f8 and then sorry free
that's a free poem but I'm threatened
denied well you have to go back to f5
and then it's not that easy but there's
a better move here of the c5 to see if I
do you want to take our usual how about
this rule Etha so you can't take on see
if I don't do that d5 is actually a big
mistake and I'm gonna try to explain
your why the best move here was rook e1
fantastic move you want to go to his
seven
[Music]
exactly the night is covering East 7 and
then you can't go Rukia you can't fight
for the file because then Luke texier
just wins well so let's say Knight to e7
so it's blacks turn here if you move the
knight to c6 in order to cover is 7 you
can even you could even play rook e7
because of the knight takes a race Queen
checkmate Queen g7 checkmate right so d5
is a terrible mistake because now black
has an option black can survive what do
you play here with the black pieces now
you know the thread yeah the thread is
rook e1 and rookie 7 so how do you stop
that
Group E eight are you sure
okay that's interesting but the best
move is Nike for now after rookie one
you just want to jump to e5 covering the
e-file and also attack in this Queen
right so d6 was played 95 attacking the
Queen 97 check
are you sure how it's a game from the
YouTube ah you remember the passer from
this okay
great teammate eight Queenie four and
now Ruki eight was played yes
f4 attacking and now the best move was
not f7 in the game black played rookie 7
what do you think happening just
happened in the game white blundered or
blacks losing why
and then Quinn takes the one check and
then King Queen d7 great Kevin you are
doing perfectly fine yeah did you train
with Fabiano koala did you train with
Fabiano Caruana these days the number
two in the world you just too strong
today
I don't remember he'd say okay rookies
haven't just loses because of retakes is
having exactly okay
so keen 878 and black had to resign okay
very interesting game by our friends
seem our some mistakes but very
interesting okay
third game if 46 how this is called even
how how these defend is called what's
the name of the opening the French okay
you know where is France Asia Europe
Africa where where tell me South America
Alaska yes but which continent yeah
Asia Europe it's in Europe okay Europe I
live very close to France I am from
Spain we have a border in common with
friends I am from Spain yeah now you
know to free may see you know Messi
okay mrs. Argentinian actually okay this
is called the advanced variation 'if
I've now black has to break this pawn
chain by and then that's why they play
c5 c5 c3 protecting the pawn chain Queen
b6 attacking it not a 396 you see that
the key is the default pawn black is
trying to attack that white is trying to
protect that so now a3 is played here in
this position it's the main move now
white is planning to go before here in
this point and then there are different
options here available for black you can
play nine eight six
for example really interesting move you
want to go to f5 and then put more
pressure or c64 followed by 97 9 ma 5
for example nitrate 6 before takes takes
and Knight f5 you don't take on before
y-yeah
exactly and now white can take on before
with the a pond and then this is
perfectly protected so that's why you
take on the for so now the default point
is wicker and then you want to go native
v and then put a lot of pressure right
but here also another possibility is
they move c4 okay yeah yeah but also
here you're like it's difficult to
develop the pieces on the queenside for
for the white player I also prefer to
take on the afore Marcy for is it's an
interesting move Knight bTW - white is
aiming to go be free here and here
that's why the main move is Knight to a5
to stop b3 but at this point black
played Knight G to e7 what do you think
about this move looks natural it's good
as bad
[Music]
okay we have a good question from the
YouTube people people are asking why
nine eight six instead of 97 the problem
with 97 could be D takes e5 with the
1986 you want to capture with the bishop
here you're first to take with the Queen
and at the before you could be in
trouble or even Bishop e3 attacking the
Queen
you are wasting two too many Tempe at
the Queen 85 be for the Queen has to go
back so that's why I prefer not at 6:00
but okay see for 90 to 97 how do you
continue with the white pieces 97 I'm
gonna give you a good hint 97 is a
terrible move III like to eat Knight b3
b3 okay yeah that's a normal move but
black can just take and their position
is around equal ya be free is natural
move you want to break the pawn chain
right but that's a there's better move
here
maybe Orlando you see something 95 is
interesting but ok I think I can just
play something like 86 and after Queen
age 5 maybe 96 and at the end you'll
have to go back so Kevin give me give me
another brilliant move I know you can do
it you are inspired today gene for
somebody saying gee Fork really
aggressive move no not not t4 not h4 so
95 s interesting but after 86 at some
point you had to go back so yes Bishop
c4 now you see this night wasn't GI time
the bishop was covering the d6 squared
now Bishop c4 just position is much
better for white because after D takes
Knight takes you attack the Queen you
are gonna jump there with a check the
king will have to move and then you'll
you take this pawn and the position will
be extremely great for white sorry ok
tell me tell ya now there is a good
reason to take on c4 because d6 not
covered right
so Queen a6 was played and now 96 check
there's only one move here to survive II
think what's a move here for black don't
go to the bad square Ethan come on you
got five seconds to the clock five four
three two one time time now King to d8
what happens here 90 xf7 fork check and
then you lose the rook so that's why
you've gotta go to where
exactly
you were right genius
so here 9 f7 was played and group has to
go back to g8 and as you can see White
has three points for a piece and then
the key is in the center so this looks
very good for white white played Queen
c2 black played g6 here and now the
white player played c4 trying to open
the position because the point wants to
come to d5 Knight a5 was played sure
Castle King to e7 the King doesn't want
to be on the D file now Knight G - sorry
Knight F - G 596 was a better move here
because after Knight g5 black could play
eight six forcing this night to go back
to a three and then black could take on
d4 even though what's better it's still
black has managed to get up on back but
okay in the game Knight g5 Knight takes
e4 Knight takes e4 takes Queen d3 not f5
roopd one what are you threatening with
group d1 Ethan if black plays h5 what do
you play here with the white pieces yeah
checkmating one yeah not very difficult
come on Ethan check made me yeah so to
give check made you have to check first
here otherwise not gonna happen to d6
are you sure
boom so so give me more checks where
where can you go come on
there are only two more checks try them
Queen d7 no good right because of bishop
takes so the other one yeah Queen to
where exactly that's it
check me check me sir so white black has
to resign that's why the black player
played Bishop g7 to cover the d8 square
with the rook and now here our friend
who was driving the black pieces he
played Bishop d2 now this Bishop is
coming to be for blacks gonna suffer a
lot here so Bishop e5 Bishop before
Bishop d6 g4 very good move king of 694
King g7 and take some f5 and actually
black had to resign very soon yeah tell
me
something before there before Bishop
takes on before the other bishop yeah
here yeah here a bishop c3 is good too
yes
but then this move is also very good
because after Bishop takes f6 the King
is very very weak now you can see that
we are even the material is balanced and
then this Bishop is doing nothing so
this is just completely lost for black
yeah so the game continued just few more
moves I'm gonna show you how it ended
but it's not interesting anymore
check Queen d8 Queen e8 takes and f7 and
then you win the rook and the game right
so I'm gonna show you the last one okay
it says hey the game which follows is an
online game which was played by me an
opponent whose name I don't know the
game had a tank control of 10 min
without increment and it was seventy six
months long game I played this black and
I am an underrated player and a regular
viewer of the YouTube channel this game
contains many mistakes and few blunders
may not be an ideal game but I assured
that is fun to watch
so g3e five-ish up G to d5 b 3 do you
know how this opening is called you know
Orlando the Papa Thomas II Papa Thomas
this animal it's a do you do you say
part of us in English hi papa Thomas
yeah yeah you know this animal right
it's the only animal who can't jump
no I mean you go for the double
fianchetto then you played III III you
bring the Knights here okay all right
so 96 it's not a very good opening since
Black now controls all the center right
but it's interesting because suddenly
you are just they're very solid in the
seventh and eighth rank and then boom
you go with some pawn break see for
later or efore or d4 depends on the
position f5 III matter of 692 Bishop d6
short Castle short Castle d3 so when I
play one minute bullet games I play
they're hyper Potamus because you like
you make like 10 moves in a row without
thinking mm-hmm
King h8 the king is in a safe place
90 c4 was played here and now D takes e4
natural move how would you take now this
point with the b-pawn or with the D pawn
why okay that's an interesting idea
but normally pawns they move toward the
center okay so you have the chance to go
toward the center normally it's a good
idea here it was better to take with the
b-pawn so you gain more control of the
center right
the problem with D takes e4 is to move
that black black played here efore now
you see this Bishop is locked out and
then black gained this interesting
square e v and in the game white player
played Knight d4 takes I liked here 95
looks much better right because you are
intending to jump to d3 you control f3
the knight is perfectly place here he 5
right so that's why Knight d4 is not a
very good move Queen takes 8 6 was
played Knight c3 b6 and here white
played Knight d5 expecting black to fall
on his trick so Knight takes e5 loses
because of Queen takes D 7 checkmate but
of course black is not gonna take on the
e5 right the other move was Knight B 5 I
really preferred this move again trying
to get the bishop er so 95 Bishop d7 was
played whoa sorry
thank you
here Bishop c5 right after 95 okay
Knight b5 here Bishop c5 I guess you
can't take on da and then the c7 pawn is
hanging so basically I think you have to
go Bishop e7 takes on the Ed and take
with the bishop and still blacks a
little bit worse but still you're
surviving here not the end of the world
so 95 was played Bishop b7 and 9f for
here and again in this game Bishop f4
was played what do you think about this
move Kevin okay
White's threatening to take two to go to
play Knight g6 right this fork may be
good alright if we don't have a good
reason to give our bishops we shouldn't
do it yeah so for example here Queenie
eight was better
covering g6 then maybe even trying to go
g5 at some point but Bishop f4 again
White has the bishop pair and it has a
better position see if I was played
Queen c3 and Queen d3 was played what do
you think about this move black play
sorry white plate root d1 but there is a
better move here come on
and then
exactly that's a blunder queen takes c3
he takes c3 and we should be seven right
so queen d3 was a terrible blunder
instead white played Group D one Queen C
3
Bishop takes c3 rook d8 and rook d2 was
played and III what do you think about
this move
you sure it's an okay move for black
again for C moves captures checks and
threats how do we win this game with the
white pieces it's very easy with the
white pieces yes even
so you want to take this pawn this is
what they played in the game and it was
not the best option Kevin and then
exactly rook takes rook takes and Bishop
e7 right easy
so F takes c3 Knight e4 yep yeah so yeah
before it's protected but even though if
the bishop worse on a6 or something you
could play keen upon something like this
right so nothing happens so 94 was
played here and then Brooke d8 rook d8
and again if you don't have a good
reason don't give your bishops so here
why to Connie for it could have gone to
e1 for example or to e5 or to be to why
it's better but here after Bishop takes
e4 black has many options of equalizing
cuz the opposite color bishops you have
many options for a draw right even a you
are a pawn down or even two points down
and you got the D file and even even
White was in trouble after some moves
Bishop e5 rook d3 rogue D to check and
now he grabbed the h2 pawn why because
he you go to a swan would you play even
discoverable yeah
it's checkmating 1 so to checkmate you
have to check first
so check to the one look to the one I
take it so the keen on h1 sorry keen h1
so if I'm think to check me you have to
check so how do you check the only
option is moving the rook right so where
do you move the room you have many
options you have d squared d squared d
squared d squared a squared a squared a
squared d squared a squared which one is
made f - do you think it's made no
because I just run to g1 so where do you
go
but but the king is in check exactly
that's made just now you kind of move
they came to the G file you cannot take
the route the route because the king is
in check so black Queens right all right
okay so I think it's 7:30 so we have to
start with chess in the Romantic era I'm
going to show you some gains from
Lowenthal who was a very good player so
thank you guys in the YouTube channel I
wait for you in the next class which
which starts in two minutes thank you
guys and see you next class
you
[Music]